night crawler
i'm afraid i'm going to have to let you
go
what why
for what reason well to put it simply i
find you very gross
gross
explain just look at you i mean you look
like you're perpetually wet i assure you
professor i'm not wet you look moist is
what i'm saying in fact you look like
the personification of the word moist
if a summer camp child said the word
moist three times in the mirror you
would appear behind them i don't
understand you look like infected gums
you look like you piss ink wait that is
highly offensive you kind of look like
1980s michael jackson just got back from
a filthy clamming expedition i'll have
you know oh god those gross hands it's
like shaking a foot one time you gave me
a back rub it felt like a pterodactyl
had perched on my shoulders it was gross
and i was more tense at the end of it
professor you established this mansion
as a haven for the mutants was this all
an elaborate trap to lure us in and then
insult us
a little bit
well then
please by all means continue great when
you teleport it smells very bad it
smells like a fat kid running around in
the summer ate like about 35 deviled
eggs and then took a hot [ __ ] in a warm
pool yes yeah it smells like
someone turned on a crock pot and filled
it with campbell's clam chowder and
about three rolls of dirty pants okay i
get it i understand i just have one more
yeah your teleportation fumes smell like
angela lansbury an older woman dressed
up in all leather slept in a sleeping
bag in a room with no windows or doors
in august and then had diarrhea from too
much sizzler buffet
that's what it smells like i mean
to a tea
good day professor
oh god smells like the predator's
dreadlocks smells like mario batali's
body cast
or my aunt's purse
filled with blue-green algae
man i wish he had heard those